good morning I'm going to discuss the
brain activity map and the future of
neuro technology and I'm going to start
by talking about what I consider is
maybe the most important challenge that
science and technology has currently
which is to understand how the cerebral
cortex work so as you probably know the
cereal cortex is the largest part of the
brain mammals it covers our encephalon
and it's a thin sheet of tissue about
two millimeters thick as illustrated
here on the right but it's actually a
flat circuit and so about two square
meters which in the case of humans is
all crumbled up inside our skull and
forming what we know is the great matter
it is straight it over here alright and
the reason i think is the most important
challenge of science and technologies
because we know now from 100 years of
our patient lesions and animal work that
the cortex is actually the site of all
the higher cognitive functions our
mental abilities are based in the
critics are generated by the cerebral
cortex and also alterations pathologist
in the cortex are and the line
essentially all the mental or diseases
and many neurological diseases so and at
the same time we still don't understand
how you work in spite of a hundred years
of solid work generation after
generation of extremely bright
scientists some of which are illustrated
here all over the world so that's the
taxpayer you could say well um where is
the goodies how come you guys still
don't know how this about cortex works
in spite of all these these efforts so
I'm going to briefly bring you up to
date as to what we've learned in the
last hundred years and then offer you an
explanation
why we don't understand it and offer
your solution as to what we could do to
understand this you were called victim I
think the minute that signs and medicine
understand how the cortex work car it's
going to be turning point in our culture
because we will understand our minds and
perfectly from the inside for the first
time so we are defined by our monetary
species it so it's not only of great
medical importance for psychiatry and
neurology that it's a fundamental
cultural importance for for us as as
humans in case so so what have we
learned I think it's fair to say that
central hypothesis that we have as a
field in terms of researchers like me
they have studied civil context is that
it's built out of repetitions of a
modular circuit and this is what I mean
in this slide which means that there
could be a strip of tissue that may have
had no 10,000 neurons with no one knows
for sure but the reason our that the
codexes evolves so quickly and has
expanded so recently in evolution could
be due to the fact that it's essentially
a developmental program that is
complicating these modules it is the
case different areas of the cerebral
cortex will have essentially the same
underlying hardware and this module has
the word the transistor of the cortex
will be the same in humans or in other
mental and species like in mice and what
makes us smarter is because we would
have many more of these modules than
mice do not necessarily because our
module would be different so now I'd
like you to consider the following idea
if this is the case that means that
everything that the cortex does is the
fruit generated by the same exact
circuit howre so now if you go to let's
say at the back of the cortex it's
involved in visual analysis of the of
the world or if you go to the front of
the cortex in human it's involving
sort of calculation of probabilities
about the future you go to the temporal
lobe define some neurons that are
responsive to particular phases of
particular people that we know so if you
move around in different parts of the
cortex you find that this computation
happened is nothing in common so at the
same time if they are indeed generated
by the same structural module the same
functional unit then this means that the
common denominator for all this
complication has to be something very
simple and you could argue that what
we're missing what we should try to
understand is what is the computational
essence of this module which I would
like them to the double helix of DNA so
just like in genetic it was a simple
model the DNA double helix which has
great explanatory power can explain a
lot of for what happens in heritance NM
the genetics you could imagine that the
cortical module could be based around
some simple circuit by a local tuning
machine that can compute anything that
can be computed and that could explain
why different parts of the cortex are
computing up this apana cool solving
these are partly completely different
computations and this would also explain
the great great success of our species
and the mammalian lineage and evolution
because we are the species in the
lineage that has this biological Turing
machine that's why we've been so
successful in evolution and if you
realize that then you can understand the
magnitude of the problem that we're
dealing with and how important it is and
it is possible that this double helix of
brains could be people say well it may
be it's very complicated but I would
argue today that we probably are taking
something very simple and then once we
see it just like it happen without helix
it will be an aha moment and people say
oh my god it cannot believe we were
looking at it for all these years so why
haven't we hit on this double helix
of the brain yet and what people have
been doing for the last hundred years is
looking at the cortex one year at a time
and for that they've used anatomical
techniques such as a golgi method so
this is an example of a drawing from
Ramona Cahal of the typical news insular
cortex of a human these are the
pyramidal cells and you have some other
cells here which are actually not
granule cells which are they inhibit
your nearest and Anna and I commit have
been looking at the cortex one in at a
time and physiology is using micro
electrodes have also been looking at the
cortex at aquatic work by noon when
you're at a time by sticking these my
collected next to the cortical neurons
in living animals in living on humans
and then we coordinate activity of the
single neurons while the animal of the
person was performing some sort of
behavioral task and then trying to make
sense out of these activities but I like
you to perform the following thought
experiment imagine you are a UFO
scientist and you happen to land in New
York City and you find the structure in
front of you and you want to understand
how it works it okay this is very
striking let me just figure out I work
and that's a good scientist you proceed
to take it apart is most individual
component and you find out that the
impart a building is peel out of atoms
and you try to study the atomic
structure of imparted building and try
to understand how it works well no
matter how long you study the atomic
structure of empire state building you
will not understand you'll never
understand what is it built for what is
the function of the building the reason
is because the atoms on bricks and the
bricks form floor plant and it's only
once you start looking at the floor plan
level and in the direction of these
floor plans with humans that you realize
what a building is and what is the
function of a building what I'm telling
you is that the function of imparted
building is an emergent property so
property that is by definition of
pressing individual elements and only
emerges from the interactions between
elements or between the structure that
this elements feel in this
case the brakes on the floor plan so now
let's go back to the cerebral cortex now
any piece of the court of any animal is
built out of tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of neurons is an
example of the primary visual cortex of
the mouse every one of these little
white dots is a neuron so you haven't
suggested now for for a long time that
may be what we're facing here is also an
emergent level functional property in
other words that these neurons so we can
see them and we can record from them in
reality they are actually designed to be
interacting with many other neurons and
together generate states which have been
called onion ensembles they have many
names you know groups assemblies
attractors unifier change anyway the
name doesn't matter these groups of
neurons by working together will build
these functional units that which the
function of this report it will be built
so if you think about that possibility
then go back and look at what we can
assit field for 100 years is we
eventually look looking at this type of
from extraction plant pots we've started
an electrode in one neuron and recorded
from it and then try to compare that
recording from another recording from
another near in another anymore put
another electrode and then try to
compare essentially comparing atoms from
one building to the next and it's
obvious that if they are emergent
properties is near on samples what we
need to do is to study them by
visualizing or recording the activity of
all the linear and so at least a large
majority of them how can we do that I
think this is the bottleneck of
neuroscience that we will facing at the
level of secondary science the
possibility that we're dealing with
emerging level property we don't have
the right techniques to do this you can
start out trying to put more lectures in
it but even if you put a lot of
electrodes you you not going to be able
to record from all the neurons and it
doesn't seem to me as the legal way to
go I would argue that
one can use light to do the job of
capturing the activity of many years at
once and visualize the possibility of
this existence of this emergent level
functional properties and life has many
advantages it's in principle
non-invasive we can be using parallels
or principle you could you could record
from many neurons at the same time and
it's also includes temporary platform it
is a message I wanted to leave you with
today is that this is the time for
Neuroscience at dinner with physics
chemistry engineering and eventually
build the new set of tools to a tackle
this problem emergent properties which
by the way it's not only a problem for
people interested in this year i
contacted prom soprano poor people
threatening don't you have any nervous
system of any species so how do you
build this these tools well I like to
think of the technical problem which is
that English lingual cortex this means i
pointed out to you earlier I'll
intermixed so it's not here we have some
of the inhibitory neurons of the sea
recordings of the mouse and withdraw
them apart from each other so you can
appreciate how different they are but in
reality you're on top of each other so
all these processes they're blue
dendrites or the red accent earth and
reality on top of each other so if you
want to use light to record or to miss
the activity of the neurons you have to
do it with two-photon microscopy because
you need a source of light that can
penetrate deep into brain tissue and
through the nonlinear excitation
properties and the fact that these two
proton lasers are infrared you can
actually use it as a as a magic one to
record the activity and record also the
structure of these needs in the middle
of brain tissue and I'm going to play
for you a movie in which you will see
how once you start using this proton
imaging methods in living tissue you
start to discover all kinds of things
are one
then as you'll see in a second is that
many of these structures that we're
dealing with are actually quite dynamic
laughs so you could play the movie are
Tracy
I hope you've you seen the movie and
realize the power of being able to use
two-photon microscopy so I would say
that the goal or far group and many
groups around the world is to enter this
field or in your wild biology in the
near science of your ensembles by
turning this type of drawings that I've
shown you from the past generations into
deciphering the circuit diagrams and
trying to find out if we're dealing with
some sort of circuit double helix in
them and to do that using two proton
lasers we need to be able to image the
activity of all these neurons to be able
to turn them on or off and finally
something that I call to tell a piano to
be able to arbitrarily turn on and off
neurons in patterns that we can actually
test whether the patterns of joint
activity of these examples are
functional and actually matter for the
behavior and the functional state of the
animal so how can we do that so I'm
going to give you some examples of how
you can do for instance imaging or
circuit activity using two-photon
microscopy and i'm going to point out
how in every one of these steps it's the
internship or interactions particularly
with researcher from the physical
sciences that have opened the door to
neuroscientists to develop this new
technique so we're really in the hands
of this intimate collaboration with the
physical sciences so how can you image
the activity of neurons well this starts
with the work of organic chemists who
designed these high affinity calcium
indicators which they change color when
they bind calcium and you can do this
either with organic chemistry and now
more recently with genetically encoded
or indicators and using these class of
indicators we actually found out by
chance that you could monitor the
activity the electrical activity of
neurons because silylated here the lower
panel whenever any on fires an action
potential these are electrical returns
from and single cell you can see a
calcium increase in the cytoplasm of the
neuron because this action point
opens calcium channels and comes to
closing so the nearly stains labor with
custom indicators if you monitor the
interstellar free calcium of the cell
you can back calculate when Denis on
fire action action potentials so this
was an unexpected finding and enable us
to look at for the first time at this
activity of of large populations of
neurons in this case you're going to be
looking at a movie in which we r imaging
the activity of 500 years in the primary
visual cortex of a mouse and these names
are going to be turning red whenever the
neurons are active trades few places you
play the movie please
ok
so I hope you appreciate how exciting it
is to look at the activity of all these
neurons is you just watch ten minutes in
the spontaneous activity of the circuit
and you see these fascinating patterns
which would study for years and the
really still clear what is that they do
but they're also present in awake
behaving animals and that's I'm going to
play you we're going to play you a
couple of movies in which you'll see
similar patterns that are occurring in
the cortex of a mouse while the mouse is
looking at screen looking at primary
visual cortex of the mouse again and
you're going to see that business are
turning on they're going to becoming red
when they turn on and you're going to
start to appreciate how they actually
the nearest like too far together in
groups they don't find eventually they
appear to be forming these potential
emerging functional groups i would
discussing earlier so traces you could
play the movie personally clip
and now um if you could play the second
movie
so um so I hope you've seen how one can
actually use these two thousand lasers
to literally look inside the brain of
awake behaving animals and watch the
activity using these calcium imaging and
using the trick that this catamenia
reflects notifying you can watch the
activity of these groups of noon so you
can in a way looking to the mind looking
to the brain of this animal while
they're performing a behavior and then
the challenge is to be able to decide
for this but this recording that I show
you um only our were first of all
recording calcium and they were also
recording the activity of five small
groups of neurons hundred to five
hundred miles and thirdly this was
imaging the activity in two dimensions
we know that neurons don't communicate
using calcium a chemical using voltage
so what we need to do is to image the
voltage of the neurons and this is
actually big challenge today because
we'd still don't have to portage
indicators to be able to perform this
type of measurements I showed you in the
way behaving animals with voltage and
the voltage only exists in the short
distance from the membrane it's all cold
are the by length of the membrane and it
is therefore very technically
challenging to be able to insert into
this the by length into the membrane
fluorescent probes that you can use for
this to Sirhan imaging of neural
activity we're going to give you an idea
of how one can try to do this nowadays
so there's for instance development of
fun normal genetically encoded voltage
indicators like art light in these cases
collaboration with Vince qurbani at Yale
and you can use these genetically
encoded indicators to measure the
voltage in the newly spines or in
dendrites facility on the right and you
can have a number of solution to see
single action potentials
maybe using the genetic League and call
it indicator at some point we'll be able
to make a movie like the one I showed
you man awake behaving animal this is
some of the work that is going on now
but still not ideal I think we really
need that big technical push there
another potential or method this would
come from actually the the world or far
quantum physics is to use nano diamonds
small atomic defects in diamonds that
happen to be the world's more sensitive
material to electric and magnetic fields
and you can actually build this nano
diamonds and couple them that's the hope
to the memory of neurons so that they
can actually be inserted within the
Debye length and measure optically the
change in membrane potential electric
field across the membrane so this is a
collaboration with the work of the
Anglin at MIT and Jennifer now and at
Columbia and maybe using nano diamonds
this is an example where physics could
help maybe it's actually the solution to
perform this high quality imaging or you
know activity in in a way behaved
animals comes from optics or quantum
optics are so this was just one problem
how to image voltage another problem
that I discussed is the fact that we're
imaging the activity of ignorance in two
dimensions but the cortex and any piece
of the brain has a two-dimensional
structure so if you really are
interested in capturing this emergent
properties you need to buy the bullet
and be able to actually capture the
activity of these volumes or cells and
there's a problem with doing this now
today because microscopes that are using
lasers like this two-photon microscope
perform volumetric imaging by serially
scanning their friend layers as
illustrated here and obviously this is a
slow method and more layers you want to
scan this lower you can devote so we've
introduced into this problem the use of
special line modulators which are liquid
crystals that can actually paralyzed the
light
you take laser beam you essentially run
it through this liquid crystal and then
using a computer you can build the face
mask in which this laser beam gets
cleaned a little bit late and you can
literally build Holograms
three-dimensional structures using light
with this esalen so you can write words
or draw pictures of github but more
importantly for discussion today you can
actually see more taneously excite
neurons located in different focal
planes and you can then capture the
fluorescent from these two neurons for
instance through the objective and
simultaneously image their activity even
though they're sitting different depths
of different depth so so we've actually
implemented this strategy using special
light modulators and what we can do is
we can take start by taking an image of
the tissue in this case it's a
two-dimensional image but it could be a
three-dimensional image we identify with
the neurons are we compute the optical
center of mass and upload these
coordinates on to the spatial light
modulator and from this point on the
laser beam gets split into hundreds of
little B blitz each other then part as a
particular cell and then we can use a
camera to single-handedly image the
activity of all these moons together
we've done this and why we when we did
this we run into the following problem
which is we discovered the fact that
microscopes in this time of lovin hug
have been built to image things in two
dimensions so even if you excite neurons
in two dimensions the rest of the
microscope still will capture the light
from a very small focal point what's
called the point spread function of the
microscopes so in order to perform this
volumetric imaging we actually have to
operate the points per function and
change the point point spread function
from something that looks like a little
point as soon as really here do
something that looks more like if like a
pencil that penetrates the entire tissue
and this enabled us are we perform this
using this optical face mask which we
insert in the optical path we can
calculate these aberration introduced
pilot
mass to essentially turn the microscope
from it to the imaging system into a 3d
imaging system and using this we can
actually our image the simultaneously
fluorescence that is present throughout
the volume of the tissue so on the left
side you have an experiment perform with
the tissue fountain in which you have
two patterns of light one of them's is
stable at the focal point and this one
with a conventional microscope you can
see it and the other one actually
migrates up and down through the focal
point and as I told you in formation on
light microscopes with conventional psf
you can only see this front pattern well
it's exactly the focal point and the
mini-date sort of moves a little bit up
or down to the top focal point it
becomes invisible without 3d microscope
using this this face mask we can still
see this from pattern across this
millimeter or worse or found tissue
panthan so it enables us to essentially
capture light that is emitted from
simultaneously from the top the bottom
of the sample this is a tissue phantom
and let me show you an experiment with
real tissue you can play the movie Tracy
you can see the activity of the
zebrafish in three dimensions could you
play a movie this is working in
collaboration with me Sharon's oh ok it
look like you know going to see the
movie anyway so this are what you would
see is the activity of 15 years in the
brain of a larval zebrafish spontaneous
activity just like I show you
spontaneous activity before of the new
code actual amount every one of these
orange dot it's an urn that's active and
you are the beauty of this movie you can
see the activity of these cells
simultaneously in three dimension x y YC
or from
or exceed so this enable that for the
first time to perform simultaneous
imaging of the activity of neimans at
the same time we're only imaging very
few neurons fit people are hundred and I
just told you that we need to buy the
bullet an image tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands your news is you
really want to capture this emergent
properties so let me touch upon arm
another challenge which is how you can
actually turn the news on with life so
you like to be able to not just to image
the activity to be able to us I told you
play the piano and interact with this
tissue and change the activity if
ideally in a way behaving animal and see
how that alters the behavior of the
animal so you can do this again this is
using a trick now learn from inorganic
chemist these are people that are
building solar cells and they use the
metal ruthenium to be light on tanner
it's an example of it with inning light
antenna and you can actually couple this
routine in violent illness to this metal
bond to know transmitters like glutamate
and then you can use to photo lasers you
break this bond and release the
neurotransmitter and this means that you
can actually optically activate the
neuron by uncaging this ruthenium
glutamate cage on top of the cell and
you live on it you make any on fire you
shine more light than your files more
and this actually corresponds to the
opening of glutamate receptors that one
would expect this collaboration perform
together with robot technical university
one of Harris's inorganic chemist so
using this cage compounds we can
actually go on and then image a group of
neurons in the tissue either in grange
slides on the living brain find our
dreams are our program the laser so that
we can go from the engineer and then you
can essentially activate the new one by
one so now you have the tools to have
single sub position and you can actually
turn the new one by one using this
routine ian by parading cage taking a
page from the inorganic chemist you can
also use these
to turn the neons off with life because
instead of linking glutamate to this
ruthenium by President you can link gaba
and you can use this to engage Kaaba on
to Papa Nora and you can use it to map
coverage receptors along at a neuron or
you can use it for example to silence
neurons and in this example with silence
ignorance using this routine Ian GABA
compounds this case is an extremely
performing legal in which we have a
rabbit's underline the growing eclectic
seizures in collaboration with Steve
Rother at University of Minnesota and we
apply this routine iam gabba on top of
the context just topically applied and
then when we shine light on the cortex
we engage will release this cabin and we
can stop this issue for a couple of
minute so this gives you a feeling for
what could be the neurology of the
future in which we can use optical
methods to come on Otis of neurons and
control princess epileptic seizures
besides turning on and turning off I
told you how the ideal would be to be
able to play again another calibers to
come on and off at will and in Iran in
any arbitrary special camp rock pattern
because obviously from the imaging the
movies that I showed you earlier you can
appreciate how are the essence to the
activity of the brain is its dynamic
it's actually the activities never
static continuously change so you have
to be able to have tools that enable you
to interfere with these dynamic
activities so a thought experiment could
be to image a pan of activities are
three frames in one of the movies that I
showed you and then use optical tools to
turn these neurons on in the same order
in which we saw them been activated and
then see that within in samples
continuous is the activity continuous
the same way that they did in the early
in the spontaneous in the animal or
during the behavior and if it if I
playing this pattern we can actually use
the behavior Indiana routine we can
change the behavior this would
demonstrate that these planets actually
are functionally critical
so we're doing this also using the
spatial light modulator and let me show
you an example of a reason experiment
using an opto genetic construct in this
case in c1 v1 it's a reason obscene
developed by the lab called a seraph at
Stanford and we've labeled hundreds of
neurons in the cortex of the mouse with
this contract and then we choose to play
the piano with this tune in this case we
play together with two fingers and we're
turning these two neurons are actually
located 20 microns off from each other
they're very close to each other and we
can perform this this experiment in
which we can file the tunes together
using this spatial light modulator this
holographic techniques that I've
discussed earlier when we shine
simultaneously in come to the two
neurons two laser beams each focus on
each of the neurons and we can fire in
together or we can fire only the top
cell even if we move the top the bottom
pattern it will be 20 microns up or the
bottom cell so we really have symbol
nearing specificity in three dimensions
with with as little as a 20 micron
Flocka change which gives us hope that
you will be able to play the piano in
two dimensions using these holographic
methods that I described earlier so um
all this method that I discuss our
methods that have been developed by
individual laboratories working in
collaboration maybe a couple of laps but
it's really i would say i'm not irish
work compared to what we need to do to
tackle this emerging level properties i
mean we still can only energy activity
or very few neurons the dimensions we
can mostly image voltage so this led to
the proposal that what we need to do
near science as a good is to create
technologies that will enable us to
tackle this emergent level system of
neil circuit and this top also was named
the brain activity map and i was
proposed together with a group of
colleagues are listed here on the
and we thought that the best strategy
for neuroscience would be to essentially
focus the work of large-scale sensitive
project similar to human genome project
that could span over a decade or they
can and a half on three major goals one
would be to develop normal tools to
measure every action potential for every
neuron in entire brain circuits and I
mean like in the Human Genome Project
you could imagine starting with smaller
circuits like in the mouse throwing the
one that has hunt three hundred neurons
of 22news and then moving as we learn
this develop these tools for bigger
animals like the brains of flies fish
mouse and eventually be able to capture
the activity and part pieces of the
human brain or human cortex I'm not
talking about imaging the entire brain
but talking about more piece of the
brains but imaging that area with single
server solutions so that you can see
principal capture every spike from every
near the second roll are both up because
we want to test hypotheses and also with
the hope of developing novel therapeutic
approaches to a mental neurological
diseases is to manipulate the activity
of Iranian in this surface to develop
number tool to be able to play a piano
with this the circuits and again to do
that in three dimensions in a way which
is relatively complete you can actually
really test if this neuron examples
encompass hundreds of thousands of new
then you need you're going to be able to
need to be able to manipulate the
articular hundreds or thousands of men
and the third goal is to develop novel
tools and other ways of thinking be able
to analyze this immense amount of data
that will come out of this this novel
methods and not only handle the data but
be able to mine the data and
computationally analyze to build models
of what the circuits to be going and is
at this level where we can actually get
a more precise idea so what is it that
we're looking for what are these
samples it's an interior mysterious
emergent properties that neural circuit
obviously these tools will have great
power and they could be misused and
because of this we argued in our
publications in our papers in a white
papers which were submitted to series of
organizations including the White House
and as you will hear later in this
series of webinars the White House
sponsor the brakiri mappa and
essentially turn it into the brain
energy initiatives that you described by
its leaders and the idea is that this
has to be a public effort this is too
important to leave for the private
sector it has to be the public running
this development of this technique and
monitoring the development of techniques
using ethical panels were
representatives from a legal profession
ethical experts and also representative
the citizenship should have their voice
heard that these technologies are not
misuse and they the respected privacy
and they can be used for the purpose of
benefiting mankind so our idea was that
this is now is the right time to do this
large-scale text technical development
and why should we do this I try to
disguise to describe some of the
scientific goals behind these novel
techniques to explore the emergent
properties of brain circuits and this
could enable us someone downs in the
future to decisive internal code to
crack these double helix of the brain
and maybe to solve the connectivity
diagrams and I discuss also there could
be great advantage for medicine not for
psychiatry and neurology using these
novel tools we may be able to develop
novel passage for brain diseases and
generate emergent hypothesis for the
pathophysiology of many brain diseases
now it's possible that these brain
diseases are not really based at the
molecular level
or at the cellular level but they are
based at the circuit or systems level so
applying Murphy's Law anything that can
go wrong will go wrong in medicine there
are molecular diseases they're going to
diseases associated with sin obsessed
with dividual cells but there should be
this easy that's ok with the function of
emergent properties of circular systems
and this is something that could come
into that's coming to into medicine from
this type of noble to development and of
course having the ability to turn it on
and off could enable us to generate
networklyra critical methods give you
some examples of optimization or brain
computer interfaces and this could be
used right away activate for epilepsy
for a patient that are paralyzed now
there's also the potential that these
tools could generate a novel technology
just like it would happen it happened
already with the human genome was 15
years after the human genome started the
economy got the benefit of about a
hundred and fourteen dollars for every
dollar that was invested into the Human
Genome Project this is the result from
the battle report so we would predict
that the same thing would happen in
neuroscience and would be just like
biotech emerged genomics emerged from
the human genome you can imagine
ceramics or neurotic could emerge from
the development of these tools and
finally I think it's very important that
this project could lead to the training
of a new generation of scientists that
are at ease in the physical sciences and
the neuroscience and this scientists are
the ones that directly push one kind
forward in understanding the brain and
using these tools for for medicine so
I'm going to skip over a movie from a
colleague and just finish up with how
this could be applied to human patients
so right now the movies that I showed
you we're taking in microscopes that
look like this not big large optical
tables these are not very easy to put
together or to run but potentially
through the use of spatial light
modulator you can imagine miniaturizing
this microscope to the point that they
could be portable the crib it be
implanted on top of the scalp of a human
patient so and even we can imagine how
you could even have a non-invasive way
of imaging through through the scholar
through a thin skull through some sort
of window into the brain of
recommendation and be able to actually
image the activity of epilepsy piece of
cortex while epilepsy is going on and
use that information to better
understand and to be monitoring maybe
change the patterns you can also image
from the inside now the work of a
neuroradiologist has developed these
novel methods that you can search
through catheter through the femoral
artery and navigate your way up into the
brain vessels and you can insert this
extra do search into brain tissue
without creating a hemorrhage and you
can implant cameras and light guys into
the brain and see from the other from
the inside sort of looking at the
binnacle from the outside you can
actually imagine doing this from the
inside and this is an example of an
epileptic patient in the future which is
taking one of these pills that has a
cage compound and imagine that show you
earlier with the mouse we were able to
stop the seizures in a mouse why not
stop incision epileptic patients
patients it have this sketch compound
floating around its brain and whenever
is issued start maybe with a lot a
bright light source that you can put it
upside its collar and with a 19 organic
LED or even a portable one you can then
flash this region of the cortex that's
undergoing epilepsy and stop the seizure
just like we did with the mouse this
would be a logical tip not on your local
therapies for the future so how could
something like a large-scale project
take off so we were initiating the brain
activity map with our writing with our
ideas and workshops bring trying to
bringing a lot of our colleagues and we
were able to convince the White House
and administrators of
ih tarpon and I said that this was
really important and they now have
started with just about to enter the end
of the first year since the park was
officially inaugurated by President
Obama's and we hope that over a decade
or they get and a half one will develop
these tools and at the end we will have
this this ready available for the entire
community and for the clinicians as well
and private foundations such as the
cavity foundation were essential in
triggering and chattering this brain
activity map project and we hope that
will they will continue pushing from the
sides and helping the federal government
federal agencies the public's money
essentially to be spending in a very
effective way by and complementing that
with their own funds and we hope that
the industry will also take on a
leadership role and particular as they
come to understand the enormous
economical benefit that will be we saw
from this tool building and they will
get involved and contribute their own
funding for this tool development I just
wanted to finish with a quote from
Sydney Brenner this is that process in
scientific answer new techniques new
discoveries and new ideas probably in
that order that even though as
scientists we think that we're very
clever and we're testing new hypothesis
at the end of the day we can only see as
far as our tools letters as a methods
lettuce and just like previous
generations have these single neuronal
tools and they develop the passenger
signs greatly I think we just need to
pass the torch to novel generations of
people that will use the new mobile
tools to try to explore this emerging
level properties of brain function and
hopefully lead us towers the
understanding or something as important
as the as the the function of our so
what autism is the functional on the
pins of our minds and to develop these
new tools we think that we need these
brains observatories its large-scale
institutes of public just like they have
in astronomy words and the regular on
testing go there and have access to this
very sophisticated
so physically method the same thing
should be true neuroscience were
individual avatars could go to a
National Center where they can actually
have access to these tools be able to
use it to test the hypothesis of the
particular piece of the brain they're
studying thanks a lot now I'm going to
be taking questions question number one
why we choose mouths for study static of
humans lies can be genetically
manipulated there are a great laboratory
animal and there's a consensus among
many labs throughout the world tour for
the last 15 20 years to use them as a
group model for the mammalian brain and
as I told you if the central hypothesis
is that we're dealing with some sort of
modular circuit we can figure out the
structure and function of this circuit
in any mammalian species and then once
we understand one piece of the cortex of
the mouth we hopefully be able to track
late to the function of entire cortex of
the humans that's the reason that people
like us are focusing on the mouth but
let me tell you that there are many many
groups around the world that are
interested in there are studying human
men interested in applying these tools
for humans either issue from on your
surgical resection or even incantation
that happen from consent to be able to
run to take a peek into the structure in
the function of ignorance ambles in
humans next question how the data
generated from this project will be
shared it's not for me to say how the
data will be shared because I'm not
writing the park I'm just I was
involving inspiring the project but as I
told you we think that is critical that
this is a public run project and that
the data should be shared open it just
likely the human genome data of course
with the privacy carrier that are
necessary to protect individual privacy
notes this seems to be the way that the
public project is being approached and
the year having these ethical panels is
something that also President Obama
announced in is the integration of the
project just about a year ago okay next
question thanks for the presentation do
you consider using other primate close
to run again I'm just a private
researcher interested in understanding
how the mascot ex works but i have many
colleagues that are work with planets
and they are already using some of these
tool in macaque monkey for example how
relevant not next question in your
opinion would be studies of connectivity
in slices and neuronal cultures well I
think they will be probably very
relevant we don't know enough yet to
answer this question properly but it is
possible that we're dealing with some
sort of very simple double helix as I
was coming you earlier and if that's the
case you may be preserved in a normal
brain slice and perhaps some of the
functional essence of those micro
circuits to be also generated in culture
as you know there now efforts to build
the colleague or columns in culture
using these organize the dimensional
culture so I'm actually optimistic that
this would give us a lot of insight into
some of the principles of how these
circuits are generated but again it's
too early to say whether the double
helix is something that you would
preserve in a culture my brain slice of
a uniquely deceiving in a way to be
hitting animal okay from the techniques
side is there a major optical techniques
that you are looking for yes as I said
I'm very interested in techniques that
enable a still image at perform
volumetric imaging to image the activity
neurons in three dimensions
simultaneously and also to image as
large numbers of units as possible I
think that's we're trying to develop our
own solution to this problem that this
is a major problem and this is a problem
where we could use help in fact other
labs around the world trying to solve
that problem but discipline
or many I think if it's an example were
perhaps a focus effort by in three
separate teams of scientists that would
have people expert in objects in
chemistry lasers and of course in
neuroscience could come up with a better
method than even the one side that we
can imagine today um okay um okay is a
public run project viable within a
reasonable period of time well it
depends on the funding behind the
project I think when we first designed
this project we were thinking of 15
years funding on a similar scale at the
imogen employed which was three billion
dollars within two years now the project
started smaller scale last year the
fiscal year 14 it was funded by a
hundred million dollars rather the u.s.
project and the next year is going to be
200 million price so it's actually it's
not even significant amount of money but
i think if this you need to be when run
topics that you really want to tackle
this this problem head on and try to
come up with with techniques that enable
us to perform this type of measurements
particularly in in in humans um next
question will you be collaborating with
international colleagues yes I'm already
ours I told you some of our
collaborators or this inorganic chemist
work in Argentina and scientists like us
don't really have frontiers we work
without limits of space or time we
collaborate with people in other parts
of the country in fact the laboratories
are international they build with people
that come from all over the world and I
think it's only natural that this
project will open up to international
collaboration because this is how
science works
in what format memory is stored in the
neuron firm I don't know I'm not sure
anyone else I think this is one of the
open questions neuroscience what is
memory how is memory physically
implemented in the brain people have
tried to understand this using single
neuron approaches but some other people
are suggested that it is maybe these new
york attractors these groups of news
working together which are a physical
implementation of memory of associative
memory it is i'm thinking of the work of
john hostel for example so there's an
open question and this is the type of
question that one would could approach
once you can actually see the acting
different part in all circles because
they can actually look to see whether
when the animal is is remembering
something you can try to have catch what
are the example of you know there are
activated you in that bad moment and
then try to manipulate this and that's
actually there's a very recent work on
from a couple of groups on the world who
starting this up technical methods could
implant false memories in mind so this
is consistent with the hypothesis that
we've been with sense of emerging level
code memory eventually if the code gets
crap maybe it can help those of us with
multiple sclerosis yes if we understood
how the model code is implemented by the
brain that super cortical spinal cord
may be able to develop tools that could
stimulate neurons in particular spatial
temporal fashion and could help patients
with multiple sclerosis another approach
on that i described is the use of brain
computer interfaces in which you could
have some assisted prosthetic devices
that can actually enable people to have
relatively normal lives in spite of
having a new identity fancies now these
are for
hopes on this is still far from reaching
that point okay you have described
determinants an activity map of the
brain as you know there is also an
effort to determine the structure deck
structure map of synaptic connection do
you think the brain can be understood
from the activity map alone are really
necessary to combine information
structure connector this is a great
question i think all information is good
this will not in a position where we can
turn out turn down any source of
information and it would be of great
importance to understand what is the
structure of the circuit that we're
trying whose functional trying to
understand i think there is already an
effort going on on this direction let's
go connect comics is now more than five
years older groups are in the world
building novel methods to essentially
map connections in using either electron
microscopy or other techniques to create
a connectivity between neurons and this
could give us essentially at some point
there the map of the hard work of these
new circuits in fact this person that'd
be looking at the screen Sydney Brenner
through his his work in chemically in
his lap the single handily decide for
the connectivity of the of the warm of C
elegans so 4 plus 300 2 years of the one
we have the connectivity diagram away
for more than 26 years but this also
shows that the perils of focusing
exclusively on the structure even though
we understood technically diagram of a
want for the last 16 years we still
haven't figure out how the brain of the
one works how the nervous system of the
reform generates behavior there's some
very exciting enrolled into that problem
but still a significant problem and I
think it's fair to say that the reason
we don't understand this part of the
reason is because we don't have the
tools to monitor the activity of the
entire maybe sitting over the world at
once if we have that if we have the
complete anatomical map with a complete
functional map
nothing would be much better serve in
our quest to try to to decipher these
these properties from the nervous system
I'm afraid we're running out of time let
me just pick up one last question oh ok
have this optical imaging method being
tested in the cerebellum yes in fact you
can perform similar imaging from awake
my some from the cerebellum if awake
nights using exactly the same methods
using calcium imaging two-photon
microscopy and we can even build these
miniature microscopes and plant them on
top of the skull of these mice wretches
through the and have some sort of farm
optical access to the internet issue and
perform these recordings in animals
while the animals are we must so with
this I'm just going to have to run to
say goodbye and thank you for your
attention